welcome back
time travelers from the future i'm steve
brenton and i'm going to tell you about
machine learning for fluid mechanics
now i am calling you time travelers
because time travels so very fast when
you're talking about machine learning
and between the time i make this video
and the time you watch this video there
may
indeed be significant changes to the
state of the art
i actually gave a version of this
lecture no more than three or four
months ago
and then found this amazing uh kind of
rendering by petro civrelis
of starry night using this kind of flow
mapping
visualization so lots of cool things i'm
going to talk about in machine learning
for fluid mechanics
in this video i'm going to focus in
particular on how we use machine
learning to model
and to control complex unsteady high
dimensional flow fields so i'm pretty
excited this is a topic very near and
dear to my heart
all right and we've already talked about
before how kind of you can
uh you can in broad brushstroke
summarize machine learning
as optimization based on data and in
particular
uh that optimization is often building
models from data
and you can use those models uh to
predict to estimate and to control
your fluid system and here's just a
small
uh a small illustration of one of some
of the many applications of fluid uh
flow
in our daily lives in in significant
industrial
uh and societal uh systems
transportation energy defense
health this is a diagram from a review
paper i wrote with barrett nowak
a few years back and again just to
remind you
most of our fluid dynamics tasks here in
blue
can be written as these really hard
optimization problems in pink
and today i'm going to focus in
particular on modeling control and
closure problems
how to pose them as optimization
problems and then how we're currently
using machine learning to start
solving these problems and i'm going to
point out at the outset
there is so much good work on this there
are hundreds of groups from around the
world
tirelessly working on implementing
machine learning to solve increasingly
hard problems
in engineering fluid mechanics a lot of
what i'm going to tell you about is from
my group and the groups of my
close colleagues and collaborators but i
do want to kind of let you know that
this is just a very very
shallow topical treatment of this really
rich and interesting
interesting subject okay so let's jump
in um
and a lot of this is going to follow
kind of some of this material outlined
in this review paper
uh with myself bert noack and petrus
kumasakis from 2020
and we're going to talk about how to use
optimization for
modeling and control in fluids good
all right so i've been kind of uh
bringing this up
over and over and over again this idea
that patterns exist in the data
and that's why we think we can model and
predict and control these fluid systems
and pattern extraction kind of the the
theory of
of you know pattern identification and
extraction
uh has a rich history and that's
actually a lot of the machine learning
uh the modern machine learning
algorithms grew out
of kind of pattern extraction theory
okay so we're going to use these
patterns in flow fields
to model to predict and to control kind
of the future evolution
of these flow fields and i love this
picture this is from a review paper by
sam tyra
and and co-authors in the aid journal
where he shows this uh kind of
correspondence between a
very complex geophysical flow this is
the flow over rishiri island in japan
uh and although this is an extremely
extremely complex
flow i mean i don't know how large a
kilometer is in this in this picture but
i mean this is on earth scale right
these are this is a mountain here
but the flow patterns actually you know
are very close to this
very very simple toy problem flow
problem that we've all been working with
uh for decades okay and so these
patterns allow us to simplify problems
but where does this complexity come from
in the first place so that's what i'm
going to start with with this lecture
okay and the complexity i like to think
of this is the navier-stokes equation
for an incompressible fluid
and this is a non-dimensional form the
complexity is really entering here
in the reynolds number term this one
over reynolds number
so as your flow becomes either bigger or
faster roughly speaking this reynolds
number
increases and the higher the reynolds
number is
the smaller the effect of viscosity
or rather viscosity acts on smaller
scales and you get more and more and
more
turbulent complex multi-scale behavior
in your flow solution
generally i'm painting with really broad
brush strokes here but the reynolds
number is kind of this parameter
that modulates the complexity of your
flow
and this is a great diagram uh i grabbed
from the feynman lectures volume two
where you have these beautiful
hand-drawn pictures of this flow past a
cylinder
as you increase the reynolds number you
see this increasing flow complexity so
you have this very simple
kind of steady laminar solution here
this is what like
tiny tiny tiny microscopic organisms
would look like their flow field
and as you increase the reynolds number
you start to see these wake structures
this carbon vortex street
then it becomes turbulent uh like the
flow of richard island
and then eventually it becomes turbulent
and kind of reattaches
so you get this incredible range of
complexity just by varying this one
parameter the reynolds number
and it's interesting you can also look
at the drag
on each of these cylinders at each of
these reynolds numbers so the y-axis
here is drag
drag coefficient the x-axis is the
reynolds number
and you see that you get this incredible
range of drag values
as you increase the reynolds number from
very very low
to very very high okay so if you drop
a ball from the leaning tower of pisa
it doesn't actually accelerate at a
constant rate given by the the
gravitational constant
because you have all of these uh kind of
various fluid forcing that's also
uh impeding or fighting uh the downward
acceleration
of of that ball so really interesting um
complexity enters through this reynolds
number and you get this massive range
of scales as you crank up that reynolds
number
okay good now oftentimes we don't care
about resolving
all of those many many scales in a fluid
system oftentimes what we really care
about are the big
dominant energy containing structures
coherent structures in the flow
so you know if you think about that that
picture of the the clouds pass richiri
island maybe i only care about those big
vertical structures and i don't care
about all of the little
turbulent structures on top okay and so
this is a picture
that anyone in fluids is is uh you know
very familiar with the kolmogorov
turbulent energy cascade and what we
have here
on a log log plot is the amount of
energy in each of these spatial wave
numbers
from low spatial wave number big low
frequency
vortices all the way up to very very
high spatial wave number teeny tiny
little vortices
and again flows are characterized by
this multi-scale in space and time
behavior
so if i look at the flow around a
submarine or a jumbo jet
i'm going to have big flow structures
that are on the length scale
of the object itself and then i'm going
to have medium and smaller and smaller
eventually getting teeny tiny little
flow structures maybe they're millimeter
length scales
and so you get this massive range of
spatial scales maybe 10 orders of
magnitude for some of the largest
industrial flows
at scale but again i don't necessarily
care about
every single degree of freedom in this
fluid i might just care about the big
coherent structures that i need to care
about for
lift and drag and noise and things like
that
okay actually noise is a really hard one
that one's not
not as easy lift and drag and so this is
the basis
of a huge effort in fluids called
closure modeling and closure modeling
basically tries to get
low order models simple models that
describe the big stuff the big energy
containing stuff
while still somehow accounting for at
least
the you know statistical effect or the
average
effect of the small scales okay and i'm
again
broad brush strokes here but that's more
or less what we're trying to do in
closure modeling
and so mathematically the way i can
write this and this is kind of just
a toy system that i've i've written down
for my own
understanding of this is that maybe i
care about the first few
big energy containing structures in x1
and x2 these are
variables that describe kind of those
big structures
and then maybe i have all of these
higher order little teeny tiny vertices
uh that are described by x3 x4 x5 and so
on and so forth
but this gives you a big coupled system
of differential equations the navy or
stokes equations is a big coupled system
of differential equations if you
discretize
or you project onto modes or something
like that and so it's really hard to
untangle the effect of these small
scales
on the big scale and that's the goal of
closure modeling
so we can't resolve all scales we don't
want to resolve all scales it's too
expensive it takes
super computers and we still can't
resolve the most industrially relevant
flows we care about today
they're too slow for optimization and
for control so we need low order models
that aren't completely accurate but are
good enough for some of our high level
objectives of design and control
okay and so the goal here is
essentially to get a proxy for these
high
frequency structures here and how they
act in the low frequency structures here
given by this expression so we want some
some
representation of the high frequency
structures in terms of the low frequency
structures
which we can then substitute back into
this first equation
which gives us this closure model so
that uh kind of boxed equation
is only in terms of the big low
frequency dominant coherent structures
and it approximates the effect of these
high frequency structures here
now this is one type of closure modeling
uh there's many types of closure
modeling there's large eddy simulation
uh there's reynolds average navy or
stokes there's unsteady reynolds average
navier stokes uran's
all kinds of uh of approaches to
this closure modeling problem this is
just kind of how i think about it in
terms of differential equations and
dynamical systems because that's how i
think about things
so we want this simplified equation okay
and that's really really hard to get so
can we start building this with machine
learning with with a wealth of data can
we start building these proxy models
uh for how the high frequency stuff
would depend on the low frequency stuff
or uh kind of averaging the effect of
the high frequency stuff in this low
frequency equation
can we start getting proxy models from
machine learning because we have
so much data from turbulence we have
massive massive turbulent simulations
there is the johns hopkins turbulence
database
stanford has a big turbulence database
many researchers around the
world are generating just server rooms
full of hard drives full of flow
simulation data of turbulent flows
can we learn from that wealth of data to
start figuring out
these closure models okay there is a
really
really
nice paper that summarizes some of these
modern efforts
uh turbulence modeling in the age of
data by durasami yakiri
yakurino and xiao and in this paper they
outline
some of the leading methods people are
using to tackle this closure modeling
problem
with data and with machine learning so
if you want to dig into this
and make progress on this extremely
important field of research
you've got to read this paper this is
this is the entry point
and on the right i have some of my
favorite papers um that are kind of
research papers on on this closure
modeling problem
you have a lot that are dealing with
reynolds averaged navy or stokes
equations which is kind of a time
averaged equation and then on the bottom
you're starting to see people
apply this to large eddy simulations
okay and this is a tiny fraction
of the the wealth of good work on
on closure modeling and one of my
absolute favorite models
out there today is this uh this rand's
closure model from
uh ling kurzowski and templeton in a
2016 jfm paper
and what i like about this this paper
and i'm gonna
i guess wax philosophical for a minute
here
whenever you want to apply machine
learning to a problem
in fluid mechanics or physical science
or engineering
i think there are kind of two approaches
one is to just
build a deep neural network throw in
your data cross-validate and get some
results
and you know write a paper and the other
approach i like
much better this is what kind of ling at
all are doing here
which is to somehow guide the learning
process with some
partial physical knowledge to constrain
your learning algorithm your machine
learning algorithm in this case a neural
network
with partial knowledge of the physics
and so what they were able to do
is modify their deep learning structure
to include
uh this this kind of last tensor input
layer
which allows them to embed known
invariants
and symmetries in uh that should be in
any closure model
and this is i think a really important
point is that
they actually went back in the
literature
well before kind of the deep learning
literature back to the 70s
and essentially found this this early
result
where researchers wrote down the navier
stokes equations
and then made a bunch of statements of
things that were absolutely true
until they hit a mathematical wall and
that
at the time in the 70s that mathematical
wall they just couldn't get around it
they couldn't solve that problem with
the tools of the era
and what ling at all did was they took
off
where that excellent paper from the 70s
left off and then they started using
better mathematical tools like these
constrained deep neural networks
to start getting these representations
and working further so i highly
recommend you do this go back to the 60s
go back to the 70s
find these classical papers and figure
out because they were so brilliant back
then they didn't have the tools
we have they couldn't just crank through
a deep neural network they had to really
think
deeply about the physics of the problem
and so if you can go through these
papers and find
where kind of they set up this problem
and where they get stuck because of
limited tools of the era you might be
able to write a new classic
uh like like ling at all did in this jfm
paper okay
i really really like this one i'm going
to link to this paper and also to
to kind of the papers that they were
based on in the comments
okay good so we've talked about how
patterns exist
you can use these to get low order
models of kind of the dominant coherent
structures without resolving all of the
teeny tiny physics
but that was still for very turbulent
problems so now i'm going to talk about
how do you actually get
reduced order models if your system is
relatively simple in the first place
and so i'm going to work with this flow
past the cylinder this reynolds number
100 flow this is kind of our starting
point in a lot of these
dynamical systems analyses and what
baron noack and colleagues showed in
2003
was that if you measure the system in
the right way if you if you pull out the
right features
from from this data these modes these
three modes
two principal components and something
he calls the shift mode
then you can essentially represent this
complex
system in a very simple
three-dimensional coordinate system
given by
by these three modes and when you
represent your system in those three
coordinates you get a really beautiful
and simple description of the flow
physics
in this case there is a slow manifold
where the dynamics
usually live and vortex shedding is
given by this limit cycle up here
at the top of that slow manifold and
they were able to derive a very simple
reduced order model
set of equations for the dynamics in
these coordinates this is
a tour de force of dynamical systems
modeling and data driven modeling
of fluid systems from a while ago
and now we're increasingly able to do
some of this with machine learning so i
think that's really exciting
so instead of kind of writing down how
the navy or stokes equation
act in those coordinates to derive this
model it's now possible to just collect
measurement data and through collecting
measurement data of those
x y and z coordinates in time we're able
to essentially build
nonlinear models for how those
derivatives behave how x dot y dot and z
dot behave
as a sparse linear combination of
candidate terms
that could be used to describe the
dynamics
okay so this is super simple you you
take your system
you trust no act that you should measure
this in
pod1 pod2 and the shift mode that gives
you time series for x y and z
and then you try to model x dot y dot
and z dot
as some sparse combination of terms like
x
or x squareds or x y's or y squareds a
sparse combination
of terms in a library and by doing this
sparse regression we call this the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics
you get a model that has only the active
terms that are needed to describe the
data
so it remains interpretable and
generalizable which is what we want for
machine learning models
especially for engineering systems where
you might need to generalize to new
scenarios you haven't seen before or
where you might need to communicate or
explain
the model and control decisions you're
making okay so this is the cindy method
and it can reconstruct this this
behavior
and essentially what you can see is this
is actually those coordinates on the
actual data this is the full simulation
plotted
in those three coordinates x y and z and
this is what the cindy identified model
looks like
so it captures the slow manifold it
captures
kind of the separation of time scales
and and everything in this model
now after writing this original paper um
shortly after
john christophe lazzo contacted me and
we started working together
to make this method a lot better and so
i want to tell you about some of what jc
has done
because again i think this is the
absolute spirit of how we should be
using machine learning for fluid systems
or for engineering systems in general so
what jc did and this made a huge
impact in our ability to model these
systems
is he incorporated two key innovations
to this modeling framework the first one
is
that he showed how you can enforce known
physics or known constraints
and so you know when we were modeling
this we were doing it very naively we
just collected the data built the
library
and did a regression to find which terms
were active
but we've known for a long time well
first of all we know that these
incompressible fluids
conserve energy that's just part of the
the physics
but more than that we know how that
manifests
itself in the equations of motion we
know that there is this skew
symmetry in the equations of motion in
the quadratic terms of the navy or
stokes equation
that kind of manifests itself as energy
conservation
and so jc showed that you could enforce
this constraint in the
cindy regression so that every model you
get
by construction was guaranteed to
conserve
energy and that's huge that means that
out of this massive space of models
where most of them are bad
we've already limited ourselves to a
very specific family of models
that are energy conserving by
construction that's huge
the second innovation and i really
really like this one too
is including higher order
non-linearities
so the original cindy model for the the
flow past a cylinder used quadratic
terms because the navy or stokes
equations has quadratic terms because
baron's model has quadratic terms
but if you allow yourself to have higher
order terms third order fifth order
seventh cubic
quintic uh septic even nonic terms
then what you get is a more accurate
model
at lower order and so essentially you're
accounting for all of the energy that
you're truncating
in your pod expansion or in your
principle components you truncate your
principle component analysis
at just the first two pca modes or pod
modes
and then the effect of all of those
those modes that you truncated
manifest themselves as these cubic
quintic nanic terms and so that's really
cool
and that gives us much better models so
that was a huge innovation
that that jc brought into this and since
then
we've looked at uh several flow systems
both the cylinder
flow past a cavity jc's looked at a lot
of other flows too
and in these systems what we're seeing
here this is just a comparison of how
this model works
um in this model here for flow past the
cylinder and for the cavity
flow the y axis is kind of a proxy for
drag
in this case and the white curve here is
what your
full high fidelity simulation the actual
flow simulation
has this kind of drag profile in white
and in yellow and blue
are the classic models the classic pod
galerkin models that everyone's been
using for
for decades are these yellow and blue
and they get the right
kind of features but they have some
pretty big errors but when you do this
cubic constrained
cindy algorithm you get much much better
agreement with the actual trends in the
data
so we have less overshoot we have the
right
rise time and things like that
and what's also really nice about this
uh that jc has shown is because you get
a sparse model a parsimonious or simple
model
you can manipulate the terms and
actually simplify it into something
that's very intuitive for a human
and so this is the model he wrote down
for flow past a cylinder
and to date to my knowledge this is the
most accurate most efficient and
simplest
model for flow faster cylinder in the
literature this is a simple
spring mass damper with a nonlinear
damping term so this is basically saying
that the cylinder flow acts like a van
der pull oscillator
really really cool and it's more
accurate than actually taking the navy
or stokes equations and projecting them
onto pod modes
so that's really cool and since then
working with jc
and with barrett noak we've been able to
show that you can also develop these
models
without having access to the full flow
field without having full flow
measurements
even if you just had lift and drag
measurements in this case on these three
cylinders you can still build very very
accurate cindy models
kind of in these lift and drag
coordinates so this gives us some hope
that we can actually use this for
control
in in the real world because we don't
need access to the full measurements
to have these models work so really cool
i'm a huge fan of kind of sparse
modeling in general
but there's been a ton of success on
this in in fluid mechanics
now i'll point out that you can also use
deep learning
to get better coordinate representations
we still built all of this on pod
or principal components and with these
deep auto encoders you can get enhanced
coordinate embeddings or better
coordinate
systems that go beyond kind of those
linear algebra techniques that we've
been using for the last 50 years
and so this is some great work by uh
kathleen champion bethany lush
nathan kutzen myself where essentially
we take this
autoencoder idea and combine it with
those sparse
cindy models in the middle layer so you
might have some high dimensional flow
data
and the idea is you build an autoencoder
to learn nonlinear coordinates
in the middle where it's simple so maybe
you go from a million degrees of freedom
down to four or five variables you care
about in this case three
and then you simultaneously add this
cindy loss function so that you get a
sparse interpretable
nonlinear model on those latent
variables i think this is a really
exciting idea for
flow field analysis and for modeling
really complex fluid flows
so i encourage you to check this out
there's also great work by bethany lush
developing these auto autoencoders that
instead of having
sparse nonlinear models in the middle
have actual linear models
in the middle and this is closely
related to coupon theory and kind of a
non-linear dynamic mode decomposition
and i'll point out that there are dozens
of groups working on this this is
probably
uh less than half of the papers that are
out on this topic
now but really vibrant field trying to
find these coordinate systems where your
dynamics are simple
okay especially important for fluid
dynamics good
so why do we care about modeling why do
we spend so much effort building these
models
well oftentimes we want to control our
system
so this is just one of my favorite
diagrams from a paper that barrett noak
and i wrote a while ago on flow control
and it just shows kind of the richness
of applications of control theory
and this is a recent paper by katarina
beaker and sebastian pites
which basically uses a deep learning
model of the fluid flow
as a surrogate that they can then use
with a model predictive controller
okay so the idea here is that you have a
complex flow system and you're going to
be controlling it to try to manipulate
its behavior
and what you'd like to do is run a
forward simulation of the actual
equations of motion of the navy or
stokes equations you'd like to run this
forecast forward
to see if your control is doing the
right thing in the future if it will be
doing the right thing
but this is far too expensive to run in
real time especially many many
trajectories
for your control system so instead what
they do
is they build this surrogate model using
a deep learning algorithm you could also
use cindy or dmd or anything else
to get this surrogate model and then you
use that surrogate model which is much
much faster
and still pretty accurate and you can
use it for control okay
uh so they've applied this uh to the
single cylinder and to the
three-cylinder configuration where you
get to rotate these cylinders and you're
trying to control like the lift and drag
on all of these cylinders so that's the
configuration here they get to
independently rotate these three
cylinders
and they're trying to track a reference
lift for the light blue
the yellow and the dark blue cylinders
so these three different lift values
and when you turn on this deep model
predictive controller it starts off not
tracking those and very rapidly the
controller
is able to to get pretty close to the
reference lift now this required a lot
of training data you had to take the
system and push on the variables and
push on the control inputs and measure
what happened
for a long time to build this deep
learning model but once you have that
expensive offline calculation
forever in the future it's fast and
efficient and accurate
okay and i'll point out that this deep
learning model
is only using measurements of the lift
and drag on these cylinders it's not
measuring full flow field information
maybe even just lift information
and what's kind of cool is if you
develop a controller
based on a model like you run the
simulation and you develop a controller
your control your model is a model of
kind of
that cylinder in the uncontrolled
scenario and when you turn on the
control
you're driving your system to a state
that it very rarely sees
this is not a normal flow state down
here and so your model is actually less
valid
down here than it was when you turned on
your controller
and so what you can do is you can
retrain your model predictive control
surrogate model
as you start to use it and you drive
your system to a new flow state you can
retrain that model
and you actually get better and better
and better performance this is much
better performance
it's more accurate and it's cheaper in
terms of the control cost
so i really like this paper i think this
is pretty exciting
there's also this great paper by erica
kaiser that points out
sheik does a comparison of using model
predictive control
based on dmd models sparse cindy models
and neural network models
and she shows that in general if you can
represent your system with dmd or cindy
you get better control performance
but i think the real hero of this is
that even for chaotic systems which
shouldn't be described by a linear dmd
model
you get this very very good fast
convergence of your control optimization
you can learn this model
on the fly with about 10 data points
and then turn your controller on so it's
extremely
efficient to train these dmd models and
to use them for model predictive control
huge huge point here if you're doing
flow control
with model predictive control please
start by using a dmd model
or a cindy model and if those don't work
definitely use a deep learning model
but it's really always a good idea to
start with a simple
model that's easy to train fast with
little amounts of data
rather than a big beefy neural network
model
i'll also point out there's a huge and
growing effort to use reinforcement
learning
in flow control problems this is very
much bio-inspired so a lot of these
papers
are using reinforcement learning for
fish swimming or for perching
or for landing uavs this is one of my
favorite papers by verma novati and
kumasakis
from pnas in 2018
where they use a deep reinforcement
learning control algorithm
to learn how to tail how one fish would
learn to tail another fish
kind of energy efficient um
kind of boat tailing and this is a
really hard problem actually um there's
some
you should go read this paper it's
excellent it's a really hard problem
the computations alone are incredibly
impressive this is a full
3d simulation of two fish swimming with
all of the you know resolved vorticity
and because reinforcement learning
requires a lot of training of different
actions
they had to run many of these
simulations so this is a tour de force
in um in in computation but also in
learning
for control so really great paper um
reinforcement learning is becoming a big
part of modern flow control with
with machine learning okay so i
i always want to point out at this point
i think this is a nice segue
that we really take a lot of inspiration
from biology in these systems we
are deeply inspired by the control
performance
of flying birds and bats and insects
and swimming fish they are able to
expertly
manipulate and interact with a complex
flow environment
with relatively few measurements without
the equations of motion
you know this eagle can fly on an empty
stomach on a full stomach in rain
after having injuries it's really
incredible
insects are especially incredible
because they don't have nearly the same
sophistication of a nervous system
as a bird yet these insects are also
able to interact with very complex
gust fields so they're able to you know
track odor plumes in a turbulent
plume they're able to respond very
rapidly to gusts that would otherwise
knock them off course they're able to
figure out
from strain sensitive neurons in their
wings what control decisions to make
ultra ultra fast and so we're just still
learning so much from these systems
and again this fits in very naturally to
machine learning
and modeling prediction control you
don't have to model
everything we don't care about all of
the degrees of freedom of your fluid
at least i don't think the moth or the
eagle do
they probably care about big dominant
coherent structures that affect their
daily lives okay
so i want to end here and i just want to
kind of tell you that this is still a
really rapidly growing field so
you know tons of opportunities for an
entire career
in machine learning for fluid dynamics
for modeling predicting
estimating and controlling these and
progress made here
will make a huge difference in
technology
societal impact industrial impact but we
also have a lot to learn in machine
learning from advancing advancing these
methods on real physical systems
uh where we know f equals m8 we know
conservation laws
so really exciting field thank you for
tuning in